this is an important story an
interesting one in terms of the culture
and how this is all working out let's
put this up there on the screen netflix
basically issued a memo to its entire
staff where in a very polite way they
say it's not actually that polite it's
basically
if you disagree with what we are putting
out you can leave so here's what they
say as employees we support the
principle that netflix offers a
diversity of stories even if we find
some titles counter to our own personal
values depending on your role you may
need to work on titles you perceive to
be harmful if you find it hard to
support our content breath netflix may
not be the best place for you
yeah
every time i was not agreeing
with
a place that i worked at
is
you staying there
things are not going to change
and that's what the company wants maybe
it's just not for you
maybe this is not for you
maybe you just don't want to work you
can't work there because you're not you
don't have the same values maybe that's
that
it's a possibility that you don't have
the same values as
a company you work for let's say for
example you don't like
palm oil
you don't like the use of it you don't
don't go work for nutella
because they be using that [ __ ]
if you don't like hold up i just want to
appreciate
me and a bunch of people at home
watching were just like there's palm oil
it was a big thing
what's wrong with palm oil i don't know
there's some people that are against it
because
it break down streets and stuff like
that and i understand that you know what
i mean
if you don't like killing animals
why are you working at the butch at the
butcher shop
you're gonna work at the bush shop and
you're going to be like you need to
change your ways
this needs maybe you're not meant to
work at the butcher shop
because you're a whole ass vegan
you know what this comes back to right
people think that you need to conform to
their views and if you don't well we're
going to change you whether you like it
or not
and that went out to all of its staff
also with the basic acknowledgement that
a lot of the people who have led these
internal revolts around the dave
chappelle special have already been
fired and i think it's actually an
important demarcation line so the people
who already was talking [ __ ] got rid of
and anybody else got a problem [ __ ] you
can leave too listen i like this and i'm
gonna just say this real briefly go
ahead
throughout this whole battle for the
last 10 years you've seen so many
corporations be terrified of how they're
perceived and they basically made it
their case that's like listen we don't
want to
we don't want no problems right and what
you saw here was because there was so
much support behind dave chappelle a
corporation thought it'd be in their
best interest to side with the talent
since the majority of the people were
with them and so from a public relations
standpoint from a business standpoint
they thought it was better for them to
go down this road i'm not saying i'm not
here today be like oh my god
corporations are amazing look at them
standing for free speech i don't believe
that at all i just think it's so great
that the people have been so behind dave
that they have not decided to cow tail
or cow
i don't know why you even say the thing
i don't know why i say it but i know
what it means didn't bow down you get
what i'm trying to say it's like big
words that's why you say that's not a
big word
i don't know what the [ __ ] that means so
whatever you know cows
yeah toes i'm not familiar with knees
and hoes
you're really trying to go with this
[ __ ]
i appreciate that but i appreciate it
you really
no i appreciate it aubry no cause you
really try to go with it you really
tried well you know cows you know toes
knees and hoes
it don't make sense but yeah yeah yeah
yeah the cows bring the milk the toes
bring the goodies the knees keep it
strong stable and the hoes bring the
boobies
the hoodies the boobies
the goodies
none of this made sense don't be mad at
some [ __ ] that nobody says in the first
place it makes sense if you fight with
me because they don't know it don't make
sense you know what what okay dave i'm
gonna fight with you hey that's what i
like to hear thank you netflix thank you
thank you netflix we appreciate it all
right please that's what we need
togetherness even though it don't make
no sense you need to shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up okay and if you think
you want you don't like it
get the [ __ ] out you don't like the hey
i don't like your views you don't have
to watch us there you go the same thing
and i don't like your views i'm not
watching you yeah unless i'm commenting
about that [ __ ] and then leaving it
alone i'm not following you fact
sometimes people yeah but you need to
stop making this kind of content and you
need to shut the [ __ ] up and keep it
pushing [ __ ]
you're not obligated to stay here that's
it you know and if we don't align with
your values you should start to
reconsider whether or not you should
subscribe here okay i'm gonna tell you
i'm gonna tell you i appreciate you all
y'all here we enjoying each other's
company it's free for you
it's work for us it's money too okay
knees and hoes okay
beautiful
you're free to leave at any point the
same way we're free to stop at any point
and that's the way that that's the way
it works
that's the thing i appreciate it i'm
gonna tell you something all right i was
actually at one point this arrogant
because it's arrogance it is arrogance i
was this arrogant to work at a job you
were sjw
no not it's not so much as hw but you
got a job and then you think they're not
doing the things right
they're not doing the things right and
you're like yo
you gotta like i think i know when i can
change the whole company and i kill
myself trying to change the company i
think the company is stupid but i stay
there i've been that person
when i'm telling you shut the [ __ ] up
i'm telling my old son hey shut the [ __ ]
up yeah you could leave schedule jet
it's not going to change
they happy with that no matter how
nonsensical this [ __ ] is i used to work
for a hotel there's this girl that came
in all right she used to be our bosses
she didn't make sense okay
she wasn't for hoteliery
she worked in restaurants all right she
didn't works in the hotel right and she
used to try to tell us how it works she
didn't know what the [ __ ] she was doing
i used to tell her uh you don't know
what the [ __ ] you i should have left
actually as a matter of fact that's what
i did i was sick and tired of that [ __ ]
i was like you'll get my patches and get
scared out let me i'm not gonna change
the company it is what it's gonna run
like that and guess what what happened
today the place just closed
she still the boss no she went to
another place that they they transferred
or they're hiring confident people yeah
yeah yeah which i'm i left i mean at the
end of the day i was right but it was
not for me to stay there and what you
want to do what you want to do it's for
me to leave maybe my intentions doesn't
match with a company i left
i i i i i took myself out yeah
listen
day is just great that dave got
supported and the right thing was done
right and we all need that from time to
time i support priests that way earlier
he said hotellery it's not a word it
isn't french but on english we say
hospitality but i support i didn't say
nothing until now that's why i looked at
you like that's why i look at the other
way
[Applause]
that's right
okay i mean
yeah hotel re what's up don't correct
nobody put the dictionary back in your
pocket [ __ ]
fmb food and beverage yeah good good
good for dave good for dave and like i
said non-site corporation i just think
it's great that the people's support i
think was reflected in the business
decision that people are making and i
think as long as we keep making that
kind of noise and we say we're not with
it corporations are just gonna decide on
the side of profits but well if the
people are not with you then we just go
with the people we just went with what
the money was that's it that the reason
why they switched it up before is
because they thought they were going to
lose their money and the reason why
they're doing this now is because they
thought they won't lose more money
we just got to make those things they're
not doing something better they're just
doing the same thing they've been doing
money best believe if dave chappelle was
joking they would have dropped that
[ __ ] no one no okay it's because
it's dave and he's that i don't like joe
coy uh some got a problem with recording
he's just not dave he's not they they
would get rid of him in a minute
they'd get rid of most comics in a
minute yeah yeah but the reason why
spotify stayed with joe rogan is not
because they love his views because it's
because they love the views he brings
okay let's be honest so as long as you
guys voice your opinions with your
dollars the companies will listen so i
just wanted to take a moment to say that
and you know what
it's not just dave
joe rogan in the during the recent
controversy where everything was going
crazy
gained two million subs
yeah
two million subs
that means at that time when everyone's
getting trying to get rid of him saying
he said this word and all this other
stuff spotify just looked at the id
check account they went
woof you're gonna have to write these
one alone yeah yeah
who's this [ __ ] old geezer who's
gonna take all this [ __ ] off bye [ __ ]
we're not doing [ __ ] india re when's the
last time you put out a single bye [ __ ]
that's what he was saying so damn at the
end of the day your voices do matter in
terms of how you spend your money you
may not see it instantly it's not like
putting out a tweet and getting the
response but i promise you if you put
your money where your mouth is it will
make a difference and it's at the end of
the day all these [ __ ] care
about is money and it's good that india
ahri did what she thought
left i i i command you for that you and
still doing and believe what you're
believing and you're doing what you're
doing i really commend you for that
because it's hard to do that and stay
like have integrity you know i mean
through what you believe and you did
that you left but that's i believe
that's what you should do india ahri did
what she did and everybody did what they
did and what they were supposed to do so
yeah whatever you want to leave leave
you want to stay stay
that's how it should be there you go let
us know what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear from you
hotallery